Oh
[Musique]
nous avons
monter et toucher
aguayo
le sonnet était avec des trames et des tissus iowa
adipeux
et nous voulions
et ceux où le terrorisme jour de la couleur
[Musique]
ceux qui ne sont pas
Merde
hier en les tuant
[Musique]
et tous
et ce n'est pas bon tarapoto de millions
conquis avec les juristes de Las Tunas
[Musique]
à présent
et
[Musique]
non
ne le perds pas
[Musique]
j'ai connu
société 2 non
[Musique]
dans la région touristique
Nous continuons
étudie ces trous
De vol
[Musique]
plus loin
bien que pas sec
nœuds stupides
l'amateur de couleurs tourisme
réconforter
[Applaudissements]
faveur soudaine
Je veux jouer à tout le monde
ici
[Musique]
l'histoire
[des rires]
[Musique]